JESSE WATTERS, AND DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
WE ARE A DIVIDED COUNTRY, WE ARE
TOLD.
PEOPLE BLAME THE MEDIA, OTHERS
POLITICIANS.
TO QUOTE FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA,
DON'T BLAME ME.
INSTEAD PUT IT ON IDENTITY
POLITICS.
>> WHEN I HEAR PEOPLE SAY THEY
DON'T LIKE IDENTITY POLITICS.
THEY DON'T LIKE -- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
IDENTITY POLITICS DOESN'T JUST
APPLY WHEN IT'S BLACK PEOPLE OR
GAY PEOPLE OR WOMEN.
THE FOLKS WHO REALLY ORIGINATED
IDENTITY POLITICS WERE THE
PERSON YOU SAID 3/5 CLAUSE NO
LESS.
THAT'S IDENTITY POLITICS.
THAT IS STILL OUT THERE.
>> Greg: HE IS DEAD RIGHT.
THE PAST WAS SUPER RACIST.
JUST ASK DEMOCRATS GOING TO WAR
TO DEFEND SLAVERY.
THAT WAS THEN.
OBAMA SEEMS TO BE ARGUING AROUND
OUR CURRENT PROBLEM, KIND OF
LIKE WHEN FACED WITH ISLAMIC
TERROR, YOU SAY THIS.
>> LEST WE GET ON OUR HIGH HORSE
AND THINK THIS IS UNIQUE TO SOME
OTHER PLACE, REMEMBER THAT
DURING THE CRUSADES, THE
INQUISITION, PEOPLE COMMITTED
TERRIBLE DEEDS IN THE NAME OF
CHRIST.
>> Greg: I DON'T BLAME OBAMA'S
WHAT ABOUT-ISM.
AN EXCUSE IS THE ONE FLAW THAT
IF FIXED COULD UNIFY HIS PARTY
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT FLAW IS IDENTITY POLITICS
WHICH PREFERS DISUNITY AND
DIFFERENCES OVER MUTUAL
UNDERSTANDING.
POLITICAL POWER BASED ON
GRIEVANCE REQUIRES AN ENDLESS
SUPPLY OF OPPRESSORS.
WITHOUT THEM, THERE IS NO POWER.
NO WONDER YOUNG HEALTHY
INDIVIDUALS WITH ENDLESS
OPPORTUNITIES FEEL AND SEEM
HOPELESS.
IT'S BECAUSE THE ANGER RUINS
THEM.
IDENTITY POLITICS AS YOU'RE
NEVER GOING TO WIN UNTIL YOU ARE
THE OPPRESSOR.
THAT MEANS EMBRACING A VENGEANCE
BASED DOGMA.
IT SAYS THAT OTHERS, NO MATTER
THEIR AGE, ARE STILL GUILTY OF A
HUGE HISTORICAL CRIME AGAINST
BLACKS, WOMEN, GAYS, YOU NAME
IT.
ULTIMATELY EACH GROUP WILL TURN
ON ITSELF SINCE ONE GROUP
SUPPRESSOR IS ANOTHER'S VICTIM.
IT REMOVES COMMONALITY,
REPLACING IT WITH GRIEVANCES
THAT LEAVES YOU BETTER.
UNTIL THE DEMOCRATS DISCARD THE
OBSTACLE TO UNITY, IT'S ONLY
GOING TO GET WORSE.
IT'S NOT OFTEN THAT I GIVE
ADVICE.
EARNEST ADVICE TO DEMOCRATS.
WHAT THE HELL AM I THINKING?
>> Dana: SNAP OUT OF IT.
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU HAVE TO
BELIEVE I BELIEVE THAT IF THE
DEMOCRATS LET GO, IT COULD BE A
MAGNIFICENT THING FOR BOTH
PARTIES.
IT WILL MAKE THE REPUBLICANS
BETTER AS WELL IF YOU HAVE A
REALLY STRONG MESSAGE, UNIFYING
MESSAGE FROM DEMOCRATS.
EVERYBODY BECOMES BETTER BECAUSE
IT'S ABOUT UNIFICATION.
>> Juan: I AM ALL FOR
UNIFICATION AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THE IDEA
WE ARE ALL AMERICANS.
BUT I DO THINK, CONTRARY TO WHAT
YOU SAID, YOU LEFT DONALD TRUMP
OUT OF THERE AND I THINK HE IS A
GUY WHO'S FOUND IT POLITICALLY
ADVANTAGEOUS TO DIVIDE US AS
AMERICANS.
AND THAT IDENTITY POLITICS MY
MIND, ESPECIALLY THE POLITICS OF
TODAY, A LOT OF IT BEGINS WITH
THINGS LIKE THE BIRTHER
MOVEMENT.
OR THE BLACK FOOTBALL PLAYERS.
I COULD GO ON.
YOU KNOW THE STORY.
MY MIND, WHAT I'M SEEING IS THE
EMPHASIS TRUMP HAS PLACED ON
WHITE IDENTITY POLITICS AND IT
HAS INVOLVED AND PEOPLE I THINK
IN THE PAST WERE BITING THEIR
TONGUES ABOUT IT.
I THINK THIS IS PART OF THE
SHIFTING DEMOGRAPHICS FOR THE
COUNTRY, ESPECIALLY AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE.
MORE PEOPLE OF COLOR, MORE
IMMIGRANTS COMING TO THE
COUNTRY.
I THINK IT CHALLENGES THE IDEA
OF WHITE MAJORITY, WHITE
CONTROL.
BUT WE NEED TO GET AWAY FROM IT.
THAT'S WHERE I AGREE WITH YOU.
FOCUS ON THINGS THAT BRING US
TOGETHER.
I DON'T THINK TRUMP IS THAT GUY.
>> Greg: MAYBE HE ISN'T, BUT
IDENTITY POLITICS STRESSES THE
DIFFERENCES, THE IDEA OF
INTERSECTION-ALITY.
WE CAN'T COME TOGETHER IF WE ARE
FOCUSING ON WHO IS MORE
AGGRIEVED.
>> Dana: EVEN MORE IMPORTANT I
THINK TO GO BACK AND REMAIN
PEOPLE AND TEACH YOUNGER PEOPLE
ABOUT CIVICS EDUCATION AND WHY
THE FOUNDERS FOUNDED OUR
COUNTRY.
IT'S BASED ON AN IDEA.
DIVERSITY IS A STRENGTH, IT'S
THE DEMOCRATS MESSAGE.
OKAY, MAY BE.
YOU CAN SEE HOW FAR YOU CAN GET
THAT WAY BUT WHAT WOULD BRING
ALL OF US TOGETHER AS A REMINDER
THAT THE FOCUS AMERICA BASED ON
AN IDEA THAT ALL MEN ARE CREATED
EQUAL.
IT'S NOT ABOUT OUR HERITAGE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT A CERTAIN PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHY WHEN MACRON BROUGHT
UP NATIONALISM OF THE SPEECH IN
FRANCH AND EVERYONE -- IN FRANCE
AND EVERYONE THOUGHT IT WAS A
KNOCK AT TRUMP.
NATIONALISM IN FRANCE,
ABSOLUTELY.
IT WAS BAD.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED.
HE TALKED ABOUT NATIONALISM IN
AMERICA, IT'S NOT BASED ON AN
IDENTITY IN TERMS OF THE PEOPLE.
IT'S BASED ON THAT WE ALL AGREE
ON THIS IDEAL THAT BROUGHT US
TOGETHER.
THAT'S THE WAY TO KEEP THE
COUNTRY STRONG.
IT'S NOT JUST DIVERSITY IS A
STRENGTH.
IT'S THAT THE FOUNDING FATHERS
SET US UP FOR SUCCESS AND WE
SHOULD TAKE THEM UP ON IT.
>> Jesse: ON JUAN'S COMMENT,
YOU SAYING THAT THEY WERE STILL
BEs FOR KNEELING.
I DIDN'T SEE IT AS RACIAL I
SIGHED AS PATRIOTISM.
TRUMP WANTED EVERYONE TO BE
UNITED.
WHEN OBAMA WAS TALKING ABOUT
IDENTITY POLITICS, HE WAS
BRILLIANT AT PLAYING THAT GAME
AND HE WAS VERY EFFECTIVE AT IT.
IT WORKED FOR HIM PERSONALLY BUT
IT DIDN'T WORK FOR HIS PARTY.
HIS PARTY GOT SHREDDED FOR EIGHT
YEARS.
TAKES A VERY GIFTED AND SPECIAL
POLITICIAN TO PULL THAT OFF
THOUGH HE DID.
THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY, BECAUSE
IDENTITY POLITICS, IT'S USEFUL
AGAINST REPUBLICANS BUT AGAINST
EACH OTHER, I THINK THEY ARE
GOING TO CANNIBALIZE THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE SO DIVERSE AND THERE'S
GOING TO BE SO MANY CANDIDATES.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE WHITES,
BLACKS, HISPANICS, MEN, WOMEN,
MIDDLE-CLASS, MILLIONAIRES.
>> Greg: NATIVE AMERICANS.
>> Jesse: BILLIONAIRES IN
THERE.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE GOING TO TRY
TO WEAPONIZE THEIR UNITY AND SAY
THAT YOU ARE A STRAIGHT WHITE
MALE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
OTHER CANDIDATES ARE SUBTLY
TAKING THE EXIT YOU COMING OR
GOING TO FEEL A LITTLE BIT OF
RESENTMENT.
IF YOU CRITICIZE A BLACK OR
HISPANIC OR FEMALE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY, THEY'RE
GOING TO TRY TO DEFLECT.
MAYBE THEY WILL PLAY THE GENDER
CARD OR RACE CARD AND THEY WON'T
ARGUE THEIR POINTS ON SUBSTANCE
AND IT'S GOING TO DO THEM A
DISSERVICE IN THE GENERAL.
I THINK WHAT HAPPENED WITH
HILLARY, SHE DIDN'T PLAY THE
GENDER CARD WHEN SHE WAS
ATTACKED BY TRUMP ON POLICY.
SHE WAS PRETTY SHARP ON POLICY
AND I HAVE TO GIVE HER SOME
RESPECT FOR THAT.
OBAMA DIDN'T ALWAYS PLAY THE
VICTIM.
EVEN ON THE ATTACK, HE WAS
PRETTY TOUGH.
I THINK THE CULTURE OF THE
COUNTRY, THEY ARE GOING TO SEE
40 DEMOCRATS PLAYING THE VICTIM
AND WHINING.
THEY DON'T SEE WINNERS.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO SEE
LOSERS.
>> Dana: HILLARY'S SLOGAN
WASN'T MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
IT'S "I AM WITH HER."
THAT WAS THE ULTIMATE.
>> Jesse: I AM SAYING THAT
WHEN TRUMP GOES AFTER HER ON
IMMIGRATION OR HEALTH CARE, SHE
DIDN'T SAY YOU ARE ATTACKING ME
BECAUSE I'M A WOMAN.
SHE CAME BACK HARD ON POLICY.
>> Greg: JESSE BROUGHT UP THE
POSSIBILITY OF 40 CANDIDATES.
I'M GOING TO THROW TO SOME SOUND
ON TAPE OF JULIAN CASTRO ON
MSNBC DISCUSSING THE IMMENSE
NUMBER OF CANDIDATES.
>> WHAT'S IT GOING TO BE LIKE TO
HAVE 40 PEOPLE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT?
>> I THINK WE NEED IT.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE GOOD
FOR THE PARTY.
WHAT HAPPENED IN 2016, WHICHEVER
CAMP YOU ARE IN, THERE IS A GOOD
AMOUNT OF BITTERNESS AFTER THE
CAMPAIGN.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
CATHARTIC FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS WHERE, AS YOU SAY,
A LOT OF TALENTED PEOPLE AND
GREAT IDEAS ARE GOING TO RUN.
THERE'S PROBABLY GOING TO BE A
LOT OF DEBATES THIS TIME.
>> Greg: JEDEDIAH, DO YOU
AGREE IT COULD BE CATHARTIC?
>> Jedidiah: I LIKE TO SEE A
LOT OF CANDIDATES BUT I THINK
IT'S GREAT TO BE CHALLENGING FOR
THEM BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE PEOPLE WHO COMPLETELY
DISAGREE WITH EACH OTHER RUNNING
FOR THE SAME POSITION.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS SO SPLIT
RIGHT NOW AND I'M CURIOUS TO SEE
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE
ARGUMENTS LIKE THEY LIKE TO
MAKE.
AGAINST THE 1%.
WHEN THEY HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN THAT LINEUP WHO COULD
POTENTIALLY BE BILLIONAIRES.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT MARK CUBAN,
BLOOMBERG.
THE KIND OF MESSAGING THEY OFTEN
DO.
I WILL SAY ON THE IDENTITY
POLITICS, I AGREE FEW, JUAN.
BOTH SIDES DO IT.
THERE IS A PROFOUND LACK OF
SELF-AWARENESS ON BOTH SIDES
WHEN THEY DO IT.
I THINK THEY DO IT BECAUSE IT
DOES WORK.
I THINK WITH YOUNG VOTERS, I
THINK WHEN THEY WENT AFTER
MITT ROMNEY ON THE BINDERS FULL
OF WOMEN, IT TOOK HIM OUT.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
RECEPTIVE TO IT BECAUSE WHEN YOU
COMPARTMENTALIZE THE COUNTRY,
THAT A WAY THAT DEMOCRATS IN
PARTICULAR I THINK MADE PEOPLE
FEEL LIKE THEY WERE BEING HEARD.
LIKE OKAY, YOU ARE A WOMAN.
THESE ARE YOUR ISSUES PARTICULAR
TO YOU.
WE ARE GOING TO SOLVE THOSE
ISSUES FOR YOU.
REPUBLICANS ARE
ANTI-CONTRACEPTION.
THEY DON'T WANT TO PROTECT YOUR
RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
IT MAKES PEOPLE FEEL FOR A
MOMENT THAT THEY ARE BEING HEARD
AND THAT THAT PERSON IS FIGHTING
FOR THEM.
IT REALLY TAKES A SECOND OF
SITTING BACK AND ACTUALLY
THINKING ABOUT HOW DIVISIVE AND
HOW DIVIDE AND CONQUER IT IS TO
BE MAD ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
IF THERE WAS A PARTY FOR SHORT
PEOPLE, I WOULD PROBABLY BE
LIKE, I AM READY TO LISTEN.
>> Dana: YOU COULD BE THE
LEADER.
>> Greg: I COULD BE THE
>> Dana: WE WILL FOLLOW.
>> Greg: YOU COULD BE MY VP.
WAIT, THAT IS SEXIST.
I WOULD BE THE VP.
>> Jedidiah: IMAGINE YOU
STANDING ON PEDESTALS AT THE
PODIUM.
>> Juan: I THINK WE COULD GET
DANA HIGH HEELS.
>> Dana: THE PROBLEM IS THAT I
AM WEARING HIGH HEELS.
>> Greg: YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE 40?
>> Juan: THE 40 DOESN'T BOTHER
ME.
I AGREE WITH JULIAN CASTRO AND
HE SAID IT WOULD BE CATHARTIC.
LET 1,000 FLOWERS BLOOM.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
INCLUDE HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Jedidiah: YOU DON'T THINK
SO?
>> Juan: I DON'T BUT I DO
THINK THE EVENT LAST NIGHT WHERE
OBAMA MADE THE STATEMENT WAS IN
HOUSTON AT THE BAKER CENTER AT
RICE UNIVERSITY.
JIM BAKER, SECRETARY OF STATE,
REAGAN, WHAT'S THE MATTER?
>> Dana: BAKER, YOU KNOW THAT
GUY.
>> Juan: IT'S A LONG TIME AGO.
JIM BAKER SAYS THE RESPONSIBLE
CENTER IN THE COUNTRY'S POLITICS
IS DISAPPEARING.
OBAMA COMES BACK AND SAYS THE
INTERNET PLAYS TO DIVISION IN
SOCIETY, MAKES A --
DIVISION SELLS.
I CAN SELL YOU DIVISION ON THE
INTERNET.
>> Greg: I AGREE.
>> Dana: ONE OTHER POINT, THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE IS
GOING TO HAVE A PRETTY STRICT
WAY OF FIGURING OUT HOW TO GET
OUT OF THIS PROBLEM.
IF YOU ARE TOM STEYER AND YOUR
MAIN ISSUES IMPEACHING
DONALD TRUMP AND THAT'S WHAT YOU
WANT TO RUN ON, I GUARANTEE YOU
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE IT TO
THE ADULT DEBATE.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE IT A
SUPER TUESDAY.
THEY ARE GOING TO FIGURE OUT A